it's great to be back together great to
be back as a party as a family and I
want to say a big thank you to Jake
Berry our chairman because organizing a
conference is a mammoth undertaking and
a big thank you to our staff our
volunteers and of course a huge thank
you to you our party members
I loved being party Channel
I really did
I got a chance to work with you all I
got a chance to work with Ben my
co-chairman and I got to work alongside
Boris
and if I remember rightly
we did okay didn't we
we got an 80-seat majority we had a
great team of MPS elected from all over
our country and with boris's leadership
we delivered brexit he got us through
covet
and of course he led the world
in our support for Ukraine
it's a legacy that he should be proud of
and I was proud to serve under him and
it's a legacy that I know Liz trust will
build upon and I've seen her take bold
action when she was foreign secretary
her steadfast support for Ukraine and
the way she stood up to Russia her
password
her passion
for the defense of our Union and her
determination to promote democracy and
freedom around the world
and as prime minister she is being bold
now helping with energy bills ensuring
that you can see a doctor promptly
reducing the taxes paid by ordinary
hard-working people across the country I
backed her from the start and I know
that I made the right choice
foreign
Secretary of the United Kingdom of Great
Britain and Northern Ireland
I I have to confess it still sounds a
little strange coming out of my mouth
but it is an honor a genuine honor to be
the face and voice of our country
overseas
I'm the okay yeah why not
I'm the UK's sales guy
uh and I like to think I'm pretty good
at sales I mean I hope so I for most of
my adult life that's what paid the bills
but I know that however good A
salesperson I aspire to be the greatest
salesperson this UK that the UK ever had
was her late Majesty Queen Elizabeth
she was our greatest Diplomat our
greatest advocate our greatest champion
she genuinely was Elizabeth the Great
and I've now also had the honor of
meeting King Charles and I know he will
work tirelessly
to continue the work that she did and be
our new great ambassador
during the funeral week of her late
Majesty I was reminded
of the standing that our country has in
the world and when I travel on behalf of
our country I'm lucky enough
to see us
to see the UK as others see us
and I can tell you the view of here from
over there is really really good
[Applause]
it's not a terribly fashionable thing to
be proud of your country
but I am
consuming
my mother chose to make this country her
home she was a young woman
from Sierra Leone who adored this
country then just as I adore this
country now indeed
indeed I am from immigrant stock on both
sides of my family as I say my mother
came here from Sierra Leone in
1966 and my dad's family came here from
Normandy in 1066.
thank you
look there will always be people that
talk down our country they will belittle
our achievements they will underestimate
our standing those self-loathing
keyboard Warriors who hate our country's
every success and pray for bad news
those are the kind of people who aren't
happy until they're unhappy
[Applause]
they're the kind of people who want to
stand on the sidelines never
contributing only moaning and bleeding
but that isn't us that isn't this party
that isn't this government that isn't
this country
we aren't commentators watching on the
sidelines saying oh I wouldn't have done
it like that we are players on the pitch
we make a difference we promote our
values we compete on the world stage for
the things that we know to be right we
believe in Freedom
we believe in the rule of law and we
believe that an aggressor cannot invade
its neighbor with impunity
and that conference is why we stand
shoulder to shoulder with those Brave
ukrainians defending their Homeland and
Britain has to have the Strategic
endurance to see this through until
their victory
foreign
February this year at the United Nations
I said
that if Putin was foolish enough
to attempt to invade Ukraine
the ukrainians would defend their
country ferociously
and they have done just that their
bravery and passion have been Amplified
by the arms and the training that the UK
has supplied and we will support them
until this war is won we will support
them until their territorial Integrity
is restored and we will support them
until the last Russian tank is dragged
Away by the last Ukrainian tractor
[Applause]
thank you
we need to have the Strategic endurance
to see this through to the end because
because if we don't
we send a message to every potential
aggressor that our resolve is fragile
and we cannot we must not we will not
send that message out into the world and
if you are listening to this speech Mr
Putin or Mr lavrov
let me be clear we will never recognize
the annexation of luhansk or donetskazon
or zapparicia or Crimea
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
and
when Ukraine has won this war and they
will
then we will support them as they
rebuild their homes rebuild their
economy and rebuild their society we
will work with our friends and allies
around the whole around the world to
hold the perpetrators to account to
punish those who use rape as a weapon of
War to punish those who knowingly Target
civilian infrastructure and to punish
those who murder women and children and
we will not do this alone
we are a member of many International
groups the Commonwealth
NATO the U.N security Council orcas the
G7 the G20
and I intend to build more alliances
more friendships more Partnerships
around the globe
that's why we have ambassadors and the
high Commissioners and diplomats in
hundreds of locations it's why I
and my fantastic team of ministers
travel the world trust me it isn't to
pick up those giant toblerones
because
although I do like those giant templates
look but when there is a war
our work on the international stage is
visible
and it's obvious
building coalitions of condemnation at
the United Nations for example
coordinating sanctions against those who
facilitate the war working to ensure
that the exports of food and fertilizer
from those Black Sea ports can continue
but much of what the fcdo does is less
visible
but no less important I've just returned
from a series of meetings in East and
Southeast Asia
I paid my respects at the funeral of
Japan's former prime minister Shinzo Abe
then I went to the Republic of Korea and
then to Singapore in each country I met
with senior ministers I met with members
of the international business Community
I set out the detail of the UK's
indo-pacific tilt
the indo-pacific is a part of the world
which is growing fast and through trade
agreements cooperation agreements and
our asean dialogue partner status we are
shrinking the distance between us
I spoke about the opportunities that are
available to us all and of course
I spoke about the role that China plays
in the region and around the globe
I made our position clear
that China could and should take a
different path
that it should adhere to the rules and
Norms of the International Community and
it should stop persecuting its people at
home and it should stop sanctioning my
friends and colleagues in the UK
Parliament
[Applause]
and was whilst I was on the other side
of the world
fcdo ministers were in the USA in
European capitals in Africa and a number
of my ministers are overseas
as I speak
because we have to invest in our
International Partnerships patient
but effective diplomacy we invest time
we invest energy and yes we invest money
because that's how we generate influence
on the world stage and that's how we
drive improvements in the lives of
people overseas and how we improve the
lives of people here in the UK
the development money that we spend our
official development Assistance or Oda
it helps women and children who have
been brutalized by conflict it helps
prevent starvation we use our expertise
in financial services through the
British investment Partnerships to
amplify the money that we provide to
part fund green energy projects for
example or to increase trade or to
stimulate economic growth in some of the
least developed countries in the world
we don't just stand idly by and watch
problems happen we step in to improve
things we're not passive but we're
active it's the right thing to do it
helps people that need our help but it
also helps people here at home in the UK
why
because safe secure and prosperous
countries don't generate refugees or
hundreds of thousands of migrants
safe secure and prosperous countries
don't export terrorism safe secure and
prosperous countries are good trade
partners for us so obviously we want to
see more safe secure and prosperous
countries that is the active role our
Oda our official development assistance
plays
but
just because we look to build prosperity
in distant places
we mustn't forget the need to build
Prosperity closer to home
a good diplomatic and economic
relationship with the EU and its member
states is good for all of us
and we've worked closely on our
sanctions packages against Russia and
those Russians that have enabled the war
in Ukraine and I want to see more
cooperation across the channel and
across the Irish sea
and addressing the current problems with
the Northern Ireland protocol is key to
doing that and I want to ensure that we
restore the Integrity of the UK internal
Market I want to protect north-south
trade but I also want to restore the
balance of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement which has been disrupted by
the protocol
I want to see all the communities in
Northern Ireland represented again at
the Stormont executive so the devolved
government can be properly
re-established and I will work hard to
get that done last week I spoke to the
eu's lead negotiator vice president Maro
sefkovic and we agreed on our desire to
reach a solution that works for all
parts of the UK especially the people of
Northern Ireland so we have the Northern
Ireland protocol Bill working its way
through Parliament and in the meantime
we continue to pursue a negotiated
settlement which respects the
Constitutional Integrity of the United
Kingdom and our single market and
supports the institutions of the Belfast
Good Friday group
[Applause]
as I've discussed
uh my fantastic
team of ministers
Vicki Ford Jesse Norman the adoptees at
Goldsmith Tariq Ahmed Jillian Keegan
well you've got plenty to keep us busy
but
it is a job worth doing
promoting Global Britain on the world
stage and I know I know but I speak to I
speak on behalf of all the ministers and
all the diplomats and all the civil
servants in the fcdo when I say
it is an honor to represent the United
Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland on the world stage because this
is a great country a country I am proud
of a country I love thank you
[Applause]